scenes is right now we're in hiatus time
for network TV shows I think this would
be a good point for me to sort of touch
base and give sort of a half way rating
of some of the stuff I've been watching
now none of this stuff I've had a
passionate enough feeling about to do
episode by episode reviews like I have
would say doctor who but you know what I
think is worth touching on since we're
kind of in the low between their first
and second halves the first one I want
to talk about is one I did not think I
was ever going to want to talk about
again Gotham if you saw my original tag
team review that i did with Ryan Daley
was not a fan of that pilot still not a
fan of that pilot however I have turned
around on the show even the second
episode things were already looking
better by the third episode which was
balloon man that was the one that turned
me around and I now actually look
forward to that show and I'm looking
forward to when it comes back below man
really was the one that turned me around
because it started to accomplish a
number of things it got a dynamic
working between Gordon and Bullock that
was more dynamic and more interesting as
they were starting to come to terms with
each other because initially they were
just banging head so hard that it was
annoying Gordon was starting to operate
in the world a little bit better he's
started to become slightly more
compromised by the situation I mean he's
still the white knight relatively
speaking but the shines off him a little
bit he's becoming more attuned to the
reality of where he is and not having
him so naively and steadfastly blindly
just going doing the right thing it
makes him more dynamic and makes it more
interesting and the beloved man also
marked the point at which they started
to bring in some of them more fun and
somewhat ridiculous elements that you
get out of a comic book world I mean a
guy a vigilante who kills people by
attaching them to weather balloons
that's kind of nuts and in that fun
comic book way and it really wasn't
until that episode that the show started
to embrace that side of it gone pretty
grim pretty gritty pretty cop show
initially and I know that's the pitch of
the show but it seemed like why would
this even have to be set in Gotham if
you're not going to embrace any aspect
of that world well they started to of
that episode and they've taken some good
aspects of that going forward the
penguin continues to be the absolute
the show but as I said Jim Gordon has
actually grown on me there been some
other good ones I really like the
interpretation of Victor Zsasz that we
got although I really could have done
without the completely superfluous
henchmen they paired him with I like a
lot of the behind-the-scenes power plays
that are going on between the mobsters I
like that it's not a flat-out war
because we've seen that a lot in movies
TV what have you an all-out mob war but
to see these two crime families of
moroni and Falcone existing in the same
world and obviously continually trying
to undermine and undercut and take over
ground from the other but not being able
to do so out in the open and still sort
of having this grudging sort of
understanding it's not really a truce
and they'd like to knock each other out
but they can't thing is interesting and
much more dynamic than I think we tend
to get Alfred's working much better as a
character he was a little schizophrenic
at first cuz they were really
reconciling his paternal instincts with
his much tougher sort of ex-military
vibe that they had decided to saddle
them with which there's nothing wrong
with that choice but they weren't really
marrying those aspects and they found
that rhythm with him since then and the
show as a whole has found its approach
to procedurals that it's now working
pretty well while still having the
continuing sort of story of largely the
crime families battling it out for
control so like I said that I really
turned around on the show and I do enjoy
it at this point there are a couple of
things that are still not working though
the big one is Barbara she has become
exactly what I was afraid she was gonna
be which is the hangar on baggage
girlfriend that heroes tend to get
saddled with she's not an asset to him
she's a liability and that is made it's
so explicit by it by an episode where he
sends her away because he's about to do
something that is gonna put him and
direct extreme danger he doesn't want
her anywhere near it what does she do
she comes back and it wasn't like one of
those cases like go see your mother I
can't tell you why she knew what he was
gonna do she knew he was in danger she
knew that her being around was gonna
make it harder for him and she came back
at that point she just became completely
worthless as a character in my eyes and
she hasn't gotten any better since the
handling of Bruce Wayne has also been a
little bit off it's been better
than I thought it was going to be partly
because they're putting on ice emphasis
on the detective side of Batman because
when batman begins in the nola movies we
got a very heavy emphasis on the combat
side of batman basically sort of the
ninja aspect of Batman and his role as a
detective was fairly underplayed now you
can't have this young version of Bruce
Wayne just kicking the butts of
criminals but you can't have him develop
his mind in his deductive skills and
they've had him doing that and it's
worked very well things get a little bit
off for me when they start having him
interact especially with other kids
because they've made him I think that
just trying to go for socially awkward
he comes off honestly as some degree of
autistic just with the extent that he
takes things literally doesn't seem to
understand normal human emotional
interactions he has to get Alfred
explaining stuff to him it just seems
off they made him a little too removed
from a normal child's life I think then
was warranted Selina Kyle cat cheese I
also kind of back and forth for me she
works fairly well when she's interacting
with adults when she's working with
Bruce and not so much i think partments
just add the line reading she gives
their their clunky part of that might be
the writing but when they try and have
her be a kid it doesn't work so well
then when they've got her sort of
functioning as a story element you know
being a character with information and
characters breaking into thing she works
better although I really really cringed
when they brought back ivy because this
was a throw-in and an odd that just it
did seems to serve no purpose and it
looks like they probably are going to
bring her back to some extent and I
don't understand why Edward nygma though
surprisingly has worked pretty well for
me the few times that they've put a more
emphasis and lingered on a bit more I
he's a little braiding but terms of his
function in the world I think it was a
pretty interesting call making him a
forensics guy that everybody's kind of
annoyed by I am now a fan of the show
but the mid-season finale really had a
lot of the problems that I
had back in the pile of that the show
had actually sort of gotten over but
then they all came back things like what
I've talked about Barbara Bruce not
really working so well bring back ivy
these nods to things in the comic but
not actually integrating them in any way
that felt meaningful so that sort of
showed me that the show can still dip
back into those early habits now even
that I'm so did not do it as badly as
the pilot the pilot was just a mess but
I'm gonna give props to the show it has
grown and has grown on me and I feel
it's actually pretty strong at this
point you know it's pretty rare for me
to see a show that just does not work in
front end and then gets steadily better
after that especially within the same
season I've seen some shows the first
seeds is not great then it gets better
the second season this was one within
that first season it even turn around
have you ever had an experience like
that what was a show that for you
started out week got better did it do it
within the first season did it take a
little while whatever it was drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned